aujourd'hui comment faire premier a
préparé sa course quand on est à la
campagne c'est pas dur tout d'abord la
campagne c'est l'idéal parce que
beaucoup moins de trafic
malgré tout il faut rouler sur le côté
gauche de la route
c'est beaucoup plus efficace et au moins
vous voyez le danger arriver ensuite si
la route vous déplaît vous pouvez
prendre comme je vais le faire là les
chemins les chemins ça c'est plutôt
sympa on a l'impression
on se souvient notre enfance pendant les
grandes vacances quand on jouait dans
les chemins mais regardez voyez le
chemin qui a juste derrière moi le
chemin c'est super il n'y a pas de
danger de voiture mais en revanche il ya
des pierres partout et ça c'est semé
d'embûches
parce que quand vous êtes fatigué que se
passe-t-il bien votre foulée ce
raccourci votre pied arras plus le seul
et le moindre caillou un peu plus haut
que les autres qui dépasse vous le
prenez et c'est la gamme elle assuré
c'est comme ça que très souvent on voit
sortir des gens des chemins avec les
genoux les coudes couronné parce qu'ils
sont tombés donc grande prudence
puis quand vous êtes à la campagne vous
connaissez pas forcément les lieux
regarder sur votre téléphone ou sur une
carte avant pour à peu près à évoluer
évaluer le pardon le tour que vous
pourrez faire et puis essayer de partir
c'est un petit truc kit astuces le vent
dans le nez
pourquoi le vent de face parce que quand
vous allez revenir ou lors et dans le
dos et comme vous seraient fatigués ça
sera beaucoup plus facile et croyez-moi
quand on est fatigué revenir avec vent
de face
c'est une grande galère écoutez moi donc
à bientôt pour de nouveaux conseils